you guys think about Christina Christian
amanpur what do you guys think about her
with CNN she hasn't has she even said
anything about this yeah what do you
think about her in general you know the
whole thing she was supposed to do an
interview with raisi and then uh you
know he said uh you have to wear the
hijab and she said I've done interviews
for the last God knows how many years 20
some years 30 years I've never worn the
hijab says now I'm not showing up to the
interview if you don't wear the hijab
and she doesn't there's a picture of her
if you want to put it up with her not
wearing the hijab with an empty chair
it's a the empty chair picture I don't
know if you have that or not type an
empty chair uh are
that's the picture right there and he
doesn't show up wow but then she does
this then a couple days later she tweets
and says you know retweets the article
about New York Times and I think she
pins it to the top then she unpinned it
about the fact that the issues taking
place in Iran is economy it's not really
you know what's going on with women and
hijab and all this it's more of an
economical issue that's going on why why
is it so here's a by the way I don't
know if you guys know or not so for some
of you guys that just joined us we have
some money on the panel right now that
minor the media criticism if you guys
are familiar with that there's a minor
called media criticism and we're going
to go to see if she can criticize some
of the media or not so for the expert on
a panel that's a media criticism
[Laughter]
why is it CNN New York Times why is it
that some of these stories like you're
just tell the story on what's going on
rather than playing politics with some
of this what is their biggest hesitation
to say Russia Putin is Hitler but in
Iran that's not really as bad it's
really only economical but but Putin is
Hitler's second coming of you know
Hitler is going to be why do they why do
they turn people like him into such you
know uh you know terrible leader Ukraine
Heroes but Iran has more economical
situation.com what do you think they're
doing it why are they playing politics
um I can't speak to Putin but um CNN has
stepped up their coverage in the last
week I've seen Jake Tapper covers it
almost nightly and they are showing the
videos they were one of the first people
that I think that showed what was
happening at shadif University and the
violence that was and the Crackdown that
was happening on the students so I will
say they have stepped up Cristiano
rampur just interviewed um Shirin ebadi
who is the first female in the Middle
East to win a Nobel Peace Prize and did
a you know her basic uh ending message
was she asked Miss ebony what do you
think should happen uh she said yeah it
has to be regime change so so they're
saying it and they're showing it now
other networks need to follow suit
I didn't find I know some people found
this problematic I felt like she was
making a statement and on this yeah no I
love that she did this okay
yeah this was great of course because
the visual was absolutely yeah yeah I
want her to do more of this show this
like hey why should women you know the
whole concept about if you don't wear a
hijab is like a woman walking around
naked that's the that's what Romani said
in 79 that a woman not wearing a hijab
is the same as a woman walking around
naked I mean and for some people to say
well that's that's the norm here we
believe that
I like this I like The Stance you took
with this one and this was right right
in the thick of I think it was just a
few days after massagina died and so she
was like of course and and they're on
American soil so it's different if she
was in Iran I'm sure she would have put
it on because she said that yeah she's
like I'm not doing it in America not an
American soul but that's that you're in
our country why am I supposed to wear
the the laws are here on my side
uh Patty John I have nothing against a
Christian I'm on poor she was born in
our street who are like neighbor
but generally and originally if you ask
majority of the Persian people
they see the origin of the Shia
branch of Islam just created by UK
there's a history on it exactly how they
send it how they designed it how uh
those majulacies showed up
Ayatollah above and above and they just
trained to speak for us everybody knows
about the uh
role that UK played Behind The Shield
so Persian people originally don't have
a good opinion about the CNN especially
what happened in the first 79. you think
that yeah most persons to me are
Democrats most Persians are CNN driven
it's pretty split these days I think
it's 60 40 is for my feeling I mean when
I was in LA have you seen the last week
purchased right in front of the CNN
building in Sunset what do I do 5 000
people there yeah but I but I think for
the most part most Iranians
60. I'll go 60 40. most of them are
Democrats so I would I would assume
that's like this we lean liberal in the
States but why do they though
why do Iranians lean liberal in the
states what's I don't know I don't know
I'm curious to know but is it does it
have anything to do with Iran or is it
more to do just pure philosophy I lean
not lean I am because of domestic
policies in the United States so I
believe in I'm pro-choice I'm lgbtq
rights I'm black lives matter so that's
me internationally with Iran I think the
Democrats have screwed up the response
not everybody is Unified in what they're
saying against Iran so I'm disappointed
in that but yeah I mean most of us are
Democrats of course because of we live
in America so that's what we want for
this country when it comes to Iran I can
see why there are I I have I know people
that socially are liberal in the US but
they have voted Republican because of
the Republicans harder stance toward
Iran so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]